you've probably heard by now that
economic inequality is historically high
that the wealthiest one-tenth of one
percent
in the united states have as much wealth
as the bottom ninety percent combined
or that the wealthiest eight individuals
in the world
have as much wealth as the poorest 3.5
billion inhabitants of the planet
did you know that economic inequality is
associated with
shorter life spans less happiness
more crime and more drug abuse
those sound like problems of poverty but
among
wealthy developed nations those health
and social problems
are actually more tightly linked to
inequality between incomes
than to absolute incomes and because of
that
the united states the wealthiest and the
most
unequal of nations actually fares worse
than all other developed countries
surveys show that large majorities of
americans both democrats and republicans
believe inequality is too high and want
more equal pay
and yet as a society we don't seem to be
able to find the
common ground the consensus the
political will
to do anything about it because as
inequality has risen
in recent decades political polarization
has risen along with it
we see those who disagree with us as
idiots or as immoral
nearly half of democrats and republicans
now think that the other side is not
just
mistaken but a threat to the nation
and that animosity prevents us from
finding the common ground
to change things
i'm a social psychology professor at the
university of north carolina
and i study the effects of inequality on
people's thinking
and behavior i'm going to argue that
it's not just an
unfortunate coincidence that inequality
and political division have risen
together
there are good psychological reasons
that inequality drives wedges in our
politics
that means there are good psychological
paths to improve both at once
to understand why inequality is so
powerful you have to first
understand that we are constantly
comparing ourselves to other people
and when we do that we really like to
come out on top and we find it painful
to be on the bottom
psychologists call it the better than
average effect
most people believe they're better than
average
at just about anything they care about
which isn't strictly possible because
that's just what average means
but that's the way people feel most
people think they're smarter than
average
harder working than average and more
socially skilled
most people think they're better drivers
than average
that's true even if you do the study
with a sample of people currently
hospitalized for a car accident that
they caused
so we really want to see ourselves as
better than average and if we find out
otherwise
it's a painful experience that we have
to cope with
and we cope with it by shifting how we
see the world
to understand how this works my
collaborators and i ran an experiment
we asked participants to complete a
decision-making task to earn some money
and in reality everyone earned the same
amount of money
but we randomly divided them into two
groups and we told one group that they
had done better than average and we told
the other group
they had done worse than average so now
we have one group
that feels richer and one group that
feels poorer
but for no objective reason and then we
ask them some questions
when we ask them how good are you at
making decisions
the better than average group said that
they were more competent than the below
average group
the better than average group said that
their success
was a fair outcome of a meritocracy
the below average group thought the
system was rigged
and in this case of course they were
right
even though the two groups had the same
amount of money
the group that felt richer said we
should cut taxes
on the wealthy cut benefits to the poor
let them work hard and be responsible
for themselves they said
these are attitudes that we normally
assume are rooted in
uh deeply held values and a lifetime of
experience
but a 10-minute exercise that made
people feel richer or poorer
was enough to change those views
this difference between being rich or
poor and
feeling rich or poor is important
because the two don't always line up
very well
you often hear people say with nostalgia
we were poor
but we didn't know it that was the case
for me growing up
until one day in the fourth grade lunch
line
we had a new cashier who didn't know the
ropes
and she asked me for a dollar twenty
five
i was taken aback because i had never
been asked to pay for my lunch before
i didn't know what to say because i
didn't have any money
and suddenly i realized for the first
time that we
free lunch kids were the poor ones
that awkward moment in the school lunch
line changed so much for me
because for the first time i felt poor
we didn't have any less money than the
day before but for the first time
i started noticing things differently it
changed the way i saw the world
i started noticing how the kids who paid
for their lunch
seemed to dress better than the free
lunch kids
i started noticing the big yellow blocks
of government cheese that showed up at
our door
and the food stamps my mother would pull
out at the grocery store
i was always a shy kid but i hardly
talked at all after that at school
who was i to speak up
for decades social scientists look for
evidence
that feeling deprived compared to other
people would motivate political action
they thought it would mobilize protests
strikes
maybe even revolutions but again and
again what they found
was that it paralyzed people because the
truth is
feeling less than other people brings
shame
it makes people turn away disgusted with
the system
feeling better than other people though
now that is motivating
it motivates us to protect that position
and it has important consequences for
our politics
to see why consider another experiment
again we asked participants to make
decisions to earn some money
and we told one group they had done
better than average and the other group
they had done worse than average
and again the better than average group
said it's a fair meritocracy
cut taxes on the wealthy cut benefits on
the poor
but this time we also asked them what
did they think
about other participants who disagree
with them on those issues
are they smart or incompetent are they
reasonable
are they biased
the better than average group said
anybody who disagrees with them
must be incompetent biased blinded by
self-interest
the below average group didn't assume
that about their opponents
now there are lots of psychology studies
showing that when people agree with us
we think they're brilliant and when
people disagree with us
we tend to think they're idiots
but this is new because we found it was
driven entirely by the group that felt
better than average
who felt entitled to dismiss those
people who disagree with them
so think about what this is doing to our
politics
as the haves and have-nots spread
further and further apart
yes a lot of us think that people on the
other side are idiots
but the people politically engaged
enough to be yelling at each other about
politics
are actually mostly the well-off
in fact as inequality has grown in
recent decades
political interest and participation
among the poor has plummeted
again we see that people who feel left
behind
aren't taking to the streets to protest
or organize voter registration drives
often they aren't even voting instead
they're turning away
and dropping out
so if we want to do something about
extreme inequality
we have to fix our politics and if we
want to fix our politics
we have to do something about inequality
so what do we do
the wonderful thing about spirals is
that you can interrupt
at any point in the cycle
i think our best bet starts with those
of us who have benefited
the most from inequalities rise those of
us who have done
better than average if you've been
successful
it's natural to chalk up your success to
your own hard work
but like the studies i showed you
everybody does that
whether or not it really was the hard
work that mattered most
every successful person i know can think
of times
when they worked hard and struggled to
succeed
they can also think of times when they
benefited
from good luck or a helping hand but
that part is harder
psychologist shy david i and tom
gilovich call it the headwind
tailwind asymmetry when you're
struggling against headwinds
those obstacles are all you can see it's
what you notice
and remember but when the wind's at your
back and everything's going your way
all you notice is yourself and our own
amazing talents
so we have to stop and think for a
minute
to recognize those tailwinds helping us
along
it's so easy to see what's wrong with
people who disagree with you
some of you decided that i was an idiot
in the first two minutes because i said
inequality was harmful
the hard part is to recognize that if
you were in a different position
you might see things differently just
like the subjects
in our experiments
so if you're in the above average group
in life and if you're watching a ted
talk you most likely are
and i leave you with this challenge
the next time you're tempted to dismiss
someone who disagrees with you
as an idiot think about the tailwinds
that helped you get where you are what
lucky breaks did you get
that might have turned out differently
what helping hands
are you grateful for recognizing those
tailwinds gives us the humility we need
to see that
disagreeing with us doesn't make people
idiots
the real hard work is in finding common
ground because it's the well-off who
have the power
and the responsibility to change things
thank you